I was at a Dodgers game and I bumped
into you and you with your son my son
you didn't remember me right
I don't recall that I think I remembered
saying hey you're that very funny
Australian comic Jim Jefferies I
remembered saying that you definitely
said that okay and then you had your son
with you who was very humble is you know
why don't I now he's three I think like
three and a half I think I matters a
little bit yeah yeah you're an attentive
dad but my question is Jim my question
is you are Australian is he growing up
with an Australian accent or an American
accent he has an American accent he
sounds like an idiot daddy I was just
wondering if I could shut up the idiot
nice he's a very is a very nice lad so
far he's doing good I'm but when he
special just came out and he was coming
home and he drove past my billboard
which is a picture do you ever I think I
said a picture I think we had a picture
yeah we haven't here there I got you
that's me that's me sitting on an eagle
with machine guns with the Statue of
Liberty on the back if you can't see it
perfectly sorry yeah fine it is I look
very thin in that picture and my
girlfriend went geez they really
photoshopped you in that picture you
look really thin I said pass I'm sitting
on an eagle yeah the great eagle yeah is
the bit where you go that doesn't look
very realistic anyway so many Suns
coming over the school and we Sun swore
for the first time and I was so proud
because I'm not athletic if I was
athletic and I saw my son throw a ball
perfectly for the first time I'd be like
a dad to me boy but I'm a hell of a
sweater yeah and just to see him do it I
just I couldn't have been and he really
snapped it and he got it right and used
it in context it was wonderful now
he's he's swore because he saw that
billboard yeah he was coming home he saw
the billboard I came home and I was
playing him video games he comes at me
goes dead
we were you riding on an eagle and I
said I was I was riding on an eagle and
he goes when did that happen I said a
few days ago anyway where was I
and I wait here at school and he went
that's
[Applause]
that boy gave epochal yeah good
you